with malvisi chairman
on Faber District Council and I'll be
chairing this meeting today
first of all may I remind you of some of
the domestic Arrangements
toilets are situated outside the meeting
room opposite the stairs
cold water is also available in the
breakout area outside the meeting room
if the fire alarm should sound please
leave the meeting room by following the
fire exit signs and meet congregate on
the Ipswich Town Football Club training
pitch
do not re-enter the building until you
are told it is safe to so do
please switch off all mobile phones
or turn them to silent
I'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being filmed
by entering this meeting you're also
consenting to being filmed by the
council and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public
and the Press
May record film photograph or broadcast
this meeting
when the public and the Press are not
lawfully excluded
and before I move to the agenda please
can I remind the councilor to counselors
to stand
when addressing your fellow counselors
and addressing the chair and can you
please speak directly into the
microphone
thank you
moving to the agenda we now have
apologies
thank you chair we have received
apologies from councilors Grandin
McLaren Andrew
thank you very much
do we have any Declarations of Interest
by counselors on any item on the agenda
no declarations
I now move to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on the 23rd of May
2023 and this is for accuracy only
so does any counselor have an issue with
with accuracy of the minutes
could I have a proposal please
councilor Parker and a seconder
councilor Huron
all those in favor
sorry
I can inform you that that has been
carried I now move to BC forward slash
23 forward slash seven
which is my announcement and I'll Stand
to read it
as your chairman on behalf of beaver
District Council I attended the 20th
birthday celebrations of the kerners
charity in Sub in Sudbury
it's a charity that provides counseling
for boys and girls men and women who are
experiencing mental health issues
I discovered that evening that the
charity now treats more males than it
does females
I also attended my first mayoral Civic
service in felixstowe
and of course July is the end of term so
I quickly went from there
to attending two School prize-giving
ceremonies
but before that I attended Suffolk day
in the center of Ipswich and I have to
have to say I was quite disappointed at
the lack of
co-chairs or comes that were in
attendance
the Royal Hospital School put on an
excellent display
of prizes
children with lots of get up and go and
ambition and drive it was really good to
see and that was quickly followed by
Ipswich High School which was much of
the same so I only hope that in this
area having witnessed two schools that
other schools share their values and
move forward thank you
I now would like I invite counselor bus
me
to make his Arrangements
I'd like to good good evening first of
all I'd like to start my announcements
by giving an update about our Coalition
administration's Collective Ambitions
for this Council term the green
independent and liberal Democrats
Coalition is built on a spirit of
partnership and cooperation it is
absolutely Central to our approach this
will be exemplified not just by how we
work together as an Administration but
how we work with our communities we want
to listen
collaborate and empower
as councilors we'll know we have now
agreed three broad themes that will
drive our agenda and be at the
coalition's heart we share these with
you yesterday so I won't go into detail
but perhaps Deborah or John would like
to say a few words about them
thank you Council Busby I will just say
a few words if I may
um it is clear that the electorate wants
to see changes to what we do and how we
do it
the change is good or at least
inevitable
these shared priorities are both
ambitious and exciting they are a
combination of continuity with many
refreshing new ideas and a strong
commitment to strengthen some of the
recent plans already proposed by the
previous administration
we will support our residents
communities businesses and environment
through greater collaboration and a real
desire to seek out Innovative projects
collaboration means with all Partners
our communities and also other councils
and organizations in the county
yes there is a greater focus on climate
change mitigation and I know some may be
skeptical skeptical due to their
potential costs but we have made it
clear that a strong economy based on
thriving towns encouraging new
businesses and improving skills is the
Bedrock on which we will meet the
climate challenges
the Administration has work to do and
I'm pleased to be part of that and
deliver against these priorities
thank you chairman
thank you
thank you councilor buzz me thank you
councilor Ward
we are an ambitious Administration as
Council award says we are committed to
change not for its own sake but because
we want to help improve the lives of our
residents the resilience of our
communities and make our contribution to
the achievement of national priorities
such as the drive to Net Zero and
biodiversity recovery our vision is to
see local communities empowered to
develop and deliver solutions to the
issues that matter to them it is our
role to bring these different
stakeholders together where the fellow
local government organizations business
or the voluntary sector to work with us
to develop new solutions to find the
funding to make them a reality we will
do things differently and we will make a
measurable difference thank you
but we must now turn these priorities
into meaningful actions to achieve our
aims alongside this work is getting
underway to establish the council's
corporate plan objectives
our resident survey so important to help
us understand the views and needs of our
communities launches this week
and our state of the district report
will be published soon
there are also lessons to be learned
from the exemplary councils we heard
from at the LJ conference a couple of
weeks ago and during a visit to the best
Council in 2022 South Staffordshire
these will all influence and shape what
we do to improve our district in the
next four years
I'd also like to take this opportunity
to welcome the news at the tour of
Britain will be coming to Bayboro on
Thursday the 7th of September passing
through a number of towns and Villages
including Hadley East bergholt and
Holbrook it's a great opportunity to
showcase our district and for
communities to come together
and I'd just like to finish by saying
I'd like to wish my ex-mother-in-law a
happy 90th birthday for today
thank you councilor Busby does anybody
have a question on a point of clarity
councilor beer could I just asked
tongue in cheek does that include
working with conservatives
welcome all contributions
okay
you went to the administration but we're
very welcome to contribute and we hope
you will in all the Committees
thank you for moving on we now have to
ask whether we've received notification
of petitions in accordance with Council
procedure rules
thank you chair and I'm received
thank you
questions by the public in accordance
with Council procedure rules
questions by councilors in accordance
non-researcher thank you
we now move to item BC forward slash 23
forward slash eight overview and
scrutiny committee annual report
2022 to 2023 and draft work plan
2023-2024
I would like to invite councilor Wyman
Vice chairman of overview and scrutiny
committee to introduce this report and
then hand over to the previous chairman
Mr John Hinton for a full run through
and to answer any questions that members
may have
councilor Wyman
thank you chair
um
just in case
um May I present paper
bc238 which is the baber overview
scrutiny committee annual report for
2022 2023 along with the draft work plan
for 2023-24.
papers note
but I'm happy to try and answer any
questions on the draft 2324 work plan
which is attached to appendix B first
I'd like to introduce Mr John Hinton
accounts for 20 years in baber our
previous ons chair to present the ons
committee annual report
2223 which is enclosed within appendix a
thank you
uh well you've all seen a copy of the
report you will also note from the
the introduction that I've I've put for
it if I do make an apology for the
length of the report on the basis that I
did say that I would try to get all
reports down to a couple of sides of A4
but this is a bit longer but it then
again it does have a lot more in it
that I think is important
I would just like to comment on a couple
of points within there one is we looked
at the parking strategy
some recommendations through to cabinet
and that involved having constant
updates on its progress which I see are
not in the new work plan so I would
respectfully suggest that they should be
added to the work plan for the coming
year I'm also pleased to see that the
the
grinning's not the right word but I
suspect it might turn into it of ending
water on the environmental issues
concerning sewage Etc is on the work
plan and I would just like to draw the
members and particularly members of the
of the new committee's attention to the
fact that it was reported in the in the
paper on the 13th of July that the
environment agency's annual report had
just been produced
and within it it said that more than
half the serious pollution incidents
where there is a serious extensive or
persistent impact on the environment
people or property were linked to
their prizes forgetting
Thames water but also angling water
in that there were 17
in serious incidents for Thames water
and 11 for anglian water so
give them a good roasting when they come
through they've got a lot to answer for
um
the other thing is that the parking I've
already mentioned and I think that that
covers all the things that I thought
ought to be added to it and wanted to
just highlight within this
um
quite happy to take any questions on the
report although I would say that the
person who did the most work on this
report is Alicia Norman
you're going to be the one
with the water polls every day
does any member have any question
Mayberry
um
thank you I'm just going to make a
comment because I am not defending
angling water at all but Mr Hinton as it
is now and
um
has just made a comment about
roasting angling water actually the
sewage issue is probably a baby issue
in water because we are the authority
that's allowed planning to have water
runoff go into sewers and I'm not
talking now I'm talking in the past
so I think we have to be a little
careful when we try and lay the blame
all at somebody's door when possibly
that's not completely right now I don't
I haven't got a whole range of
Faber planning
documents in front of me from the 70s
but I do know that water runoff that
actually goes into the sewers is the
biggest issue of why
a lot of sewage actually goes into our
rivers and sees I'm not saying it's good
idea I think it's a terrible idea but I
just think we ought to be a bit careful
sometimes that we are not apportioning
blame to someone
and perhaps it's not all on their
doorstep
counselor Mr Hinton I apologize
I'm not getting any money for the money
for this um
just to come back on that and say the
word roasting was used from the point of
view of the intensity of the questions
and
uh approached the two angling water and
approach that they take to these things
having served for probably 15 years on
the planning committee
I know the changes that have happened in
terms of development and where it's
taken place a lot of
most gears up until last year but I
haven't seen a report from last year
60 of the development took place Babel's
development took place in The Villages
rather than in the towns now obviously
that's going to put a strain on sewage
systems but within the report for each
planning application is a section
whereby England water are consulted as a
statutory Authority as to whether or not
they have capacity to deal with it
now building regulations have changed
over several times over the last few
years when I bought my first house
building regulations said that it should
all surface water from the house
should be directed into soccerways in
the front and rear Gardens not into the
sewers
when they privatize the water companies
they change the building regs and water
was that water authority said please let
us have the water from from these houses
because it will help flush out the
sewers and it will also give us a
throughput
and so water with building regulations
changed so it wasn't angling water's
fault they requested it but it was
building regulations that changed
they've changed again now in that of
course we've got studs
for those that are not familiar with the
anachronisms sustainable Urban Drainage
Systems where
that doesn't obviously help the
historical situation where you've got a
lot of houses that were built with with
their roof water Etc going straight into
the sewers
now anybody who who's got a house that
has got water going straight into the
sewers from their downpipes they can get
a rebate of 35 pound a year for manglion
water if they divert all that water into
water butts and save it and use Garden
I've got 11 water buds collecting water
around my house and I get 35 pound a
year back from angling water because
what doesn't go into those water butts
goes into the old septic tank at the
bottom of the garden which is filled
with rubble and used as a soak away
so there are ways around it so anglian
water had plenty of chance to turn
around and say look we want a
contribution from developers to increase
the capacity at our sewage plants Etc if
they felt that that was needed
and when we see of sewage runoff
happening when we've got dry weather
then that I'm afraid means that more
roasting needs to be done during the
cross-examination of anglian water
do councilor Davis you had a question
and perhaps counselor Harum
yeah well I think Mr Hinton is
absolutely underlined the point I was
going to make
about him as a counselor and as a person
totally thorough totally professional
nosy stuff and for 20 years he's been
doing that so I'd like to pay tribute to
the report that he's produced the ons
for the work that he did last year I was
on the other side of it he may remember
and I was up in front of you and and
your committee you know but you're very
fair very decent and and produced
results as well so from me and and
possibly other counselors thank you very
much great job done over a long period
of time
foreign
thank you councilor Davis
councilor whymond you have anything else
to add nothing Gerald them to say
councilor mabry's point on on the water
side is completely very relevant and
it's something we have we have actually
already spoken about in relation to the
planning I think probably it should be
an aspiration and ambition for the count
at some point in time to take on uh you
know the process of dealing with that I
think
now this reporter is for noting
thank you very much Mr Hinton it's nice
to see you here again
no there's no it's just for noting
can you make a brief
please
talking brief you know I like brief
reports
but I have to say I thought this was
fantastic I loved the layout and the
design it was very clear very easy to
read and so congratulations
stand longer reports like that for those
new members who probably don't know is
all about I tend to think of the cabinet
as the heart of the council but ons is
the head it looks it listens it
questions
it's really important now all of these
committees you can go along to if you
want to know what's going on in Vapor I
mean ons committee is as good a one as
any
plug over
thank you very much councilor Busby
okay as I said previously this is for
noting
Now we move to BC forward slash 23
forward slash nine changes to the
Constitution and I invite the monitoring
officer to introduce the report
thank you chair very briefly the report
seeks approval for the council council's
Constitution to be amended to reflect
the intention of the council that the
appointment of the leader being made on
an annual basis
as the Constitution stands at the moment
it only allows four yearly
approvals
the additional words in the Constitution
will only be or as the council shall
decide which gives the council the
option to Future levels or any time any
time the council desires to change the
um annually every two years three years
or four years so the option is there but
this is purely and simply
to sort out the intention that the
council at the last meeting to have an
annual leader
thank you
now could I have a proposer
for this report councilor Mabry and a
second councilor plum
okay now we move to
questions
counselor Riley
there's a point of order
I don't remember noting the draft work
plan for 23-24 we heard the Magnificent
report and we complimented the people
putting together but we do have
appendix B the draft work plan we lost
it to be noted it hasn't been
reintroduced and hasn't been discussed
remember it being noted
I stand always to be corrected
it was part of bc23 forward slash eight
um and it is just the work plan so it
will alter and we've moved on from that
item on the agenda
now or later to change the work plan
yeah
all right you're a member of the
committee I am indeed so you will have
the opportunity that's nice thank you
very much
okay we now move to questions on the um
town and Parish elections
I've lost the place here
oh yeah so we are moving to questions so
I got up there right okay any questions
anybody
councilor Busby
yes does or as the council shall decide
also come under two months two two weeks
and three days and 14 hours does that
come under that as well
or is it only every annual
thank you good question councilor Busby
no it's it's annually so one year two
year three year or four years
there are other Provisions there are
other Provisions within
um I think it's article four
Cinema Chancellor halt
ah
thank you
um do I take it from this paper
so during the last term that we will
have a discussion
on the committee based system is coming
forward and this isn't going to prevent
that discussion because we were promised
last term that that would come forward
early in this Administration for a sort
of debate whether we continue with the
cabinet system or revert back to a
committee based system this proposal
seems to me as if we're not going to do
that we're almost cutting that off and
by allowing an annual change we're not
going to have that debate so can I have
some reassurance that that debate will
occur and a time frame please
um certainly the debate will occur will
take place we thought that we ought to
give new members into such a high uh
number of new members this time
uh an opportunity to experience at least
one of the systems either cabinet system
before we make the decisions to wear the
revert to committee committees or not so
it will come forward in the four
okay
um councilor Parker wants to come in and
cancel a halt afterwards I'll have
councilor Parker first then your comment
and then the monitoring officer but I
think
we need to clarify that this is to
address the rotation of leaders because
of a coalition structure
whereas moving from cabinet to committee
was a was something from the past
that raised discussed and will come
forward in due course but councilor
Parker thank you madam chair um in which
case I'll um I'll try and be brief and
not live with the point but but actually
to pick up on councilor Holt's Point
um actually as we have uh as councilor
Busby has mentioned it what actually is
the mechanism for having that discussion
um
presumably has to be proposed does it
not by Council
but with the report
but then that would be the cabinet
councilor Holt
I seem to remember that the previous
administration debated that and there
was a proposal put forward and it was
voted and it was accepted by that in
previous administration that this debate
would occur in a set time frame of a new
Administration be informed which that
has now been formed and yet we have not
had any discussion any communication
from the current Administration as to
when that debate will occur so could we
please look back and confirm that the
previous administration did have a vote
the vote was carried and that that was
promised that this debate would occur
within I believe a certain number of
months of a new Administration
okay councilor
macro then councilor beer
yes I recall the discussion on that
on myself and as I recall it was a
matter that was obviously a decision of
the previous administration this is a
new Administration I I think as as the
Busby has pointed out is only reasonable
for new councilors to experience the
current system and
how it can work
I think a certain amount of time is
reasonable my understanding would have
been that if a report would be prepared
presumably from the monitoring officers
and then be brought to the council for
discussion looking at the various
options and I recall a previous
monitoring officer looking at a variety
of models there is a paper of about two
years so back I think under mbu which
proposed a variety I was on the sort of
sliding scale and I believe that paper
could be revived and brought back to
council but as a specific time frame I
don't think it was actually at a set but
I think the point is made but reasonably
it's not on the agenda no it's not it's
also a separate issue from the one we're
discussing tonight so
I gave I gave the member
a bit of leeway and you've taken you
know give a man a mile and you'll take
the whole bloody robe yes
so it's not on the agenda councilor beer
if you can answer briefly
I note your comments
um I agree
mainly with a continental Corps it was
debated it was promised that it would
come to the new Council I think all
members are aware of that and I don't
think it should be delayed any longer
than it needs to be I accept what you're
saying that perhaps day needs it but I
think a lot of members are used to
working in committees and groups but uh
um we have the document yeah you've got
the document but it must be looked at
sooner rather than later thank you
sooner than now
so uh
save the species
level so the council this was what was
resolved by Phil Council and this was
back in uh March 2022 I believe
um so that Council considers the
findings of the Constitutional working
group and resolves to retain the leader
and cabinet model of governance and
Implement additional measures to engage
with all members of baby District
Council and the critical bit is and
agree that a further review of
governance Arrangements be undertaken
after the ordinary elections in May
2023 so you're absolutely right we are
now after those elections officers that
can now look at that and consider how
best to bring that forward I would
suggest like last time that would
involve creation of a constitutional
working group to look at it because
trying to do that in detail at full
council is probably not the right way to
go happy to take that away and do that
with suitable pace
it's not on the agenda we need to move
forward
in terms of it well it needs to be done
my understanding is that it wouldn't be
if we decided I'm going to change it
wouldn't happen until
May or the new fine
itself there is no point in rushing it
tomorrow because what if we make the
decision tomorrow
it just sits there for 10 minutes so we
will do it and it will be implemented if
need be before the next Council yeah
okay
you wish to make a comment counselor
Mabry please be briefly it's a point of
order and I'm sorry to our chief
executive but you actually do have a
constitution working party because it's
me
it's Council award
councilor Jameson and there's somebody
else and I can't remember who it was and
I'm terribly sorry
um so there is one there is one
okay
thank you very much counselors
and officers moving forward
do you wish to see anything before we
moved
to the boat
no no no okay councilors can you go on
to vodka and place your vote
you know how that works the big cross in
the right hand side
and then you click voting
and it's highlighted
councilor Riley can I take your vote
please
thank you
councilor Smith
um can I take your votes oh it's just
gone through that's fine thank you
chair that's 27 4 and one vote against
and one conflict of interest
okay so that is carried
we now move to BC forward slash 23
forward slash at 10. greenhouse gas
report 2021-2022
and I would like to invite councilor
Potter to intro introduce this item and
to move the recommendations councilor
Potter
good evening thank you chair
this is my first uh report the
greenhouse gas report for 2021.
the main points I've put together for
this report is 13 pages in total the
organizational boundaries and scopes
the organizational boundary has been
taken to be those emissions from the
council's council's own headquarters the
touchdown points the street lighting
Vehicles owned by Council third parties
delivering Council services that result
in emissions of greenhouse gases there
have been three Scopes that have been
defined by the protocol for accounting
and Reporting purposes
the first scope
oil boilers premises gas Leisure Center
gas petrol diesel diesel grounds gas oil
scope 2 premises electricity
highways lighting Leisure Center
activity and the third scope
staff business travel third party diesel
third-party HBO tnd premises electricity
tnd Street highways electricity and
finally Leisure Center gas and the gas
extruded from Endeavor house this brings
about total gross divisions of
4754.9 tons
of
carbon emissions
[Applause]
the greenhouse gas emissions also is
included by sector it includes waste
Fleet Leisure Center
remaining Estates Endeavor House
business travel and Street lighting
the largest source of emissions came
from four Council owned Leisure centers
these were run by Abbey cross Leisure
and Everyone Active they accounted for 1
636.7 tons of CO2 emissions or 34 of
total carbon emissions from Council
activities which we will see in table
2.1 in the report
in chart 2.2 there was a marginal
increase in electricity however there
was a problem with the natural gas since
it has now returned to pre-pandemic
levels
in waste and refuse collection
the third largest source of emissions
within the council's portfolio was to
waste refuse collection scheme sorry
service at
826.8 tons of CO2 per annum
from August 2021 the waste Fleet began
to use hydro-treated vegetable oil
which has a far lower emissions Factor
than standard diesel
the emissions Factor associated with hvo
is not included in the calculation
it is a temporary measure to reduce
emissions
and the longer term low carbon solution
is presently being sold
in chart 2.4 you'll see there's a
summary of the co2e emissions for Waste
surfaces during the last four years
the impact of moving to HBO since August
2021 could be seen in the decrease in
emissions over 20 21 and 2022
in the report it also mentions the
transition to carbon neutrality
the trajectory of chart 3.1 shows a
baseline starting from 2018 to 90 of
5804.1 tons of CO2 towards carbon
neutrality in 2013 which of course the
Net Zero that you'll want to get to in
2019-20 this Rose to 5820 tons of CO2
emissions before falling to
4821 in 2021
20 21 and 22 this saw a marginal
decrease on the previous year to
4754.9 tons of CO2
however this must be seen against the
backdrop of lifting pandemic
restrictions
and the reopening of leisure centers it
is therefore very encouraging that the
CO2 emissions have not returned to
pre-pandemic levels
it will though be very challenging
to maintain this level of reduction as
the economy begins to recover and
activities return to free pandemic
levels
meeting the carbon neutral Target by
2030 will rely on the successful
implementation of the council's carbon
reduction management plan which will
require a significant level of funding
so forecasting decide decarbonization it
is not possible to forecast an accurate
picture of the level of funding that
will be required and these
determinations will need to be made on
the project by project basis
however it is possible to use a general
rule
using various tools
psd's use of funding cap limit of 500
pounds over tons of CO2 over a lifetime
of 15 years overall of the project
to see if the projects are worthwhile
the recent project councils delivered
using psts grants was a saving of worth
330 pounds over the tons of CO2
emissions
the psds grant was in a total of 1.4
million
and will deliver annual Savings of Circa
280 tons of CO2 in table 3.0
this provides a summary of forecast
level of investment needed using the
following assumptions
the prices are set at 2021 levels
as the psds evaluation tool is designed
for evaluating projects to retrofit
buildings only from buildings are
included in the forecast
it is assumed that compensate will will
only come from decarbonizing the heating
of the Leisure centers and the built
estate
so the PB has now been fitted to most
roof spaces in Leisure centers and
systems to decarbonize Heating
these include s or C pumps which will be
seen on an uplift in energy consumption
so reducing CO2 emissions from delivered
electricity has been excluded
Endeavor house has been excluded as well
as the council has no control over the
building's development strategy
it is assumed that it will be feasible
to decarbonize the heating of all
buildings
and now to part the report
okay well they're very close to the end
I will only just go to the
recommendation set forth
and the recommendations are that the
contents of the ghg divisions report at
appendix aides the report be noted and
that there is a task and finish group
that is established review and refresh
actions in the carbon reduction
management plan
I think I will have to leave it there
um before I open it up to questions
we are being filmed and it is going out
over the Internet so can you explain
what psds are for those who are watching
us
this is language that's very new to me
as well uh chair so I would like to
defer to uh by associate
okay thank you right then councilors we
move to questions anything
oh I need the second of first because
counselor Potters proposing are you
going to Second cancel or register yes
thank you very much super
questions over to you and then councilor
beer
um another terminology question really
in this report it mentions touchdown
points and I asked two separate
communities what these were because no
none of us worked out what it was
um and everybody thought it referred to
American football
so can somebody Define what in the
touchdown point is we actually know now
but it was
there were a far better terminologies
for it such as co-working space and hot
desking than touchdown point which is
nobody understood and these people
worked in three different government
government departments
I can try and attempt to answer that on
Tim
it seems to be the touchdown points you
refer to are remote working locations
which are between each and every set of
points so they can be designated as a
touchdown point
but other than that
I think they are they say they are just
remote working locations I think that's
my understanding of it
and up and then councilor Davis
um thank you madam chairman thank you
thanks for support for that support that
was very good I did manage to follow up
I don't say I understood at all but I
did follow up quite well
um and this may not be down to you but
page 68 uh Table Three overview of solar
carport project Kingfisher
um it goes on to say the system was
commissioned in September 2022 an
evaluation of the system performance
will be carried out once the system has
been run on for six months well that has
been stock go up and running and I don't
know what's happening has this ever
happened has the system
um
performed well and have we got some
something an evaluation that you can
tell us
because uh you know
those people in the Sudbury great
cornard area I think it's a big white
elephant sitting there thank you
I think your question could be answered
by
Fiona
and yes the soda comports are
operational and there was a temporary
issue with them which everyone I'm sure
will be aware of
um that some of the components were
replaced which did lead for to part of
them being closed down but this the
systems have been operational since the
main Works were complete and we are
still waiting for
um what it won't show in this report but
in the next report which is being
drafted at the moment we will start to
see the outcome from that intervention
so we will get a report back thank you
madam chairman thank you
understand that when top councilor Davis
okay one was really just a response to
the question about touchdown points uh I
was a portfolio holder at the time when
they were really started to be
introduced and it was part of baber's
flexible working which allowed officers
as has been explained different faces
that they could go to work and not
necessarily have to come to because it
was when we were moving from Hadley to
Endeavor house and there were core
touchdown points quite really just
because officers could just touch down
into an area and and do their work
remotely and it's as simple as that yeah
so a touchdown at the time was a popular
phrase you
at the time
so I have councilor Mabry then councilor
Riley then councilor Jameson
[Music]
chairman um at the moment I've got four
questions would you like them one after
tough
oh no
oh we are in questions that's all right
then
um my first is
um and I say this with a lot of
experience and it would be nice to know
if any other counselor here has an air
source heat pump
oh
lovely a few of us four of us well there
any used to be me so I'm delighted
um so my first question is we are using
no they're not noisy
um we are using a lot of natural gas for
our Council built estate
um has there been any investigation into
moving these into to using air source
heat pumps before somebody says well it
depends on the builder of the property I
understand that but surely we should be
moving to that as I'm sure my colleagues
here will also agree with me that if
they are run properly
mine is very efficient and very cheap to
run
and I'm sure other people will hopefully
agree with me so why are we not doing
that that's question one thank you
again this is a question I will refer to
to Fiona
ire
um a certainly consideration to look at
getting as many
State Properties as possible onto
alternative methods of
um
fuel as you've already pointed out it's
not it's not that easy with some of them
so some of the councils state for
example or the Depots and obviously
there's other conversations going on
around the depot so it's whether the
investment is is right at the right time
and but certainly
um there's a new
um social housing public sector
decolonization fund being just about to
be launched that's something we very
much will look at in terms of how we can
introduce further
um air source heat pumps as appropriate
into some of the council state
particularly things like sheltered
housing
thank you thank you you very much
thank you my fan club will be watching
and asking me and will be telling me off
if I haven't asked enough questions
um
we also talk on page 65 about Endeavor
house now we're in this building and
um I'm sure you all are aware so far
that the building has either really hot
or well you get to Winter and it's
really cold
and it says in this last sentence as
such these emissions are reportable but
outside the council's Direct Control I
understand that
are we putting on the level that
actually own this building to make sure
that this is better run I.E that they
have
exchange system we 'd be absolutely
marvelous for this building
and some of the heat in the summer could
obviously be used to heat places that do
need heating such as Care Homes and
hospitals and that's during the summer
thank you
thank you councilor Mabry I can only
share your optimism that that is the
case with Endeavor and we do have that
kind of system
uh I can only furthermore edit detail to
Fiona once more again about what that
will be
uh with uh Suffolk County council with
regard to their house but but the
reality is we are leaseholders of the
space that we have in Endeavor house we
don't we don't have
um we don't have in a legal sense we you
know we're not party to whatever method
they use to heat
the building and I will take away your
question and ask our director of Estates
and assets to see how what those
conversations have been recently
and hopefully we will have a reply all
counselors please
um now my next question is also on page
65 and it's about Council staff claiming
and traveling expenses
um
that which seems a lot to me and I'm
actually going to put my next two
questions together and it's the same
with counselors claiming traveling
expenses like
we and I'm sure it's the same for staff
we claim traveling expenses because the
building when we have to attend here for
some of this is such a long way away
from home
um and I I think that the public needs
to understand that not all of us are on
suitable public transport systems that
we can use that and not
um and not
um claim mileage now some of us do
actually bring in passengers so we do
try and share but my question to you and
I think it will happen I'm sorry
councilor Potter I think it'll have to
go to Fiona is how are we going to help
reduce all these mileages
thank you
I think this will have to go to uh viola
so a
again we have a couple of documents that
we're working to one is the government
production management plan which I have
already mentioned the other one is our
sustainable travel plan and
um we're already doing uh quite a lot of
work with staff and we engage in an
organization called Mobility ways who
did some survey work with staff to find
out how they how they get to work for
example and we're using that data at the
moment to have a look and see what
um incentives we can introduce or
support mechanisms to
um
persuade staff to to move around in
different ways
but it's not easy as you quite rightly
point out we're a rural district and
um you know they're
they're aren't always bosses or
Alternative forms of Transport so it's
very much work in progress
well I've got other people waiting to
ask questions if you've got questions
okay
um the figures are you quoted for 2021
which we all know was a
strange year for for business since it
it covered the whole of the pandemic so
there was quite a significant change in
the way that staff worked and from that
point onwards we've seen much big
increase in working from home so I'd
expect the figures probably to be
reduced by that and the fact that we
hold online meetings as well
okay councilor Riley you had a question
you're gonna jail I had asked you two
questions
um and the first question of course is
if you look at page 66 that goes into
that paper we are looking at the figures
for 21 to 22 and so we are now looking
at figures which are what 15 months old
and the question is where are we now
with 22 to 23 because it is at least 90
days since the close of the year uh the
municipal year and the question is why
don't we have up-to-date figures why are
we rattling around asking of note
figures that are 15 months old you know
why are we doing this
I'm
unfortunately
did you right I'll refer to Fiona once
again
so um yes I accept this as an older
report and we are working on the current
uh 22-23 Missions at the moment and
there is a time delay because you have
to gather all the data and so you can't
publish it on the day that uh at the end
of the 22-23 period and we're very uh
we're expecting to bring that report
back later in the Autumn so we'll catch
up so to speak but but you're right we
are these figs are a little bit historic
but we
by government on our website
and I can just add to that if I'd been
able to cover to the rest of the end of
the report I would have also said that
this was due to go into progress in
September
so the autumn
sorry if you don't like the answer
Jamison you have a question and then
cancel a date oh sorry Council O'Reilly
oh sorry
my second question goes back to page 66
and it is table chart number 3.1
and I appreciate now these figures are
well you know 15 months out of date
nevertheless uh 2122 indicates we were
failing to meet our targets we were
moving away from this straight line uh
progression that was decided upon and
what we haven't heard and what I would
like to hear actually is are we back on
target are we you know are we let you
know stay away from it
uh you know where are we
I think we agree we would all like to be
on track for the government mutual and
aspiration we've had covid actually
worked in our favor rather than against
it we have natural gas which obviously
is rising we would like to reduce that
in any way we could see fit uh we this
will require have a lot of investment in
order to bring it back into into control
and uh we're all very aware of that
Fiona would you like to add anything
um
what that uh these figures I think
someone mentioned earlier these figures
are on the back of uh two years
effectively of pandemic when many of the
actions in the carbon reduction
management plan didn't perhaps move as
as quickly as they could because we had
to deploy staff onto other other
activities
um we are I fully expect to see the 20
20 22 23
um
trajectory to be much more positive
okay
right I've got counselor Jameson
councilor Davis and
sorry I don't know your name
so cancel the show right okay
thank you madam chair I've only got one
question
um I see the the um Mission derived from
third parties are in scope three where
we have a little control
but are we using our influence to
challenge these contractors
on their plans to carbon neutral on
their plans to be carbon neutral and if
not can we start challenging
organizations in the supply chain
yeah I would like to have the ideas to
answer that
we obviously work closely with
businesses particularly around the grant
schemes that we've got so we have a net
zero Grant available in baber at the
moment I have to say the take-up has not
been as good as we would have liked in
spite of lots of promotion of it so
um we will continue to push push that
Grant scheme uh hard and I think there's
probably uh
at Suffolk level as well as part of the
stuff at climate change partnership to
really drill down and work with
businesses to to support them
because Challenger courses that we've
got a high number of small businesses
and they're already grappling with
challenges around cost of living Etc so
it's how we how we can help them to see
the benefits of switching to things like
Greener fuels Etc and because they also
save the money potentially as well as
being better for the environment
thank you
counselor Davis
yeah thanks my question really is these
figures are
fairly old but surely this should have
been foreseen I mean
councilor maybe at the beginning of her
remarks talked about her fan club and
you know the public have the right to
know and she's she's concerned about how
far she has to come to the office from
lavender but is it worth reminding the
public that it was councilor Mabry and
her conservative colleagues that forced
the Moon from Hadley to Endeavor house
in the first place so they not Factor
this in at the time did they not look at
this did they not take notice of that
and
and my question is
and my question is do you regret the
decision to force us out of that
handling
use your numbers
thank you
um point of order
um this I think is unfair councilor
Davis be because the if you were there
at the time
yep fine you voted against it
it's just a point of order because he is
accusing us of doing something as a
conservative group that we didn't
well no it's it's not it's it's it's a
point of order and it is unfair and it's
unfounded
the debate so
I come to counselor saw counselor Holt
after counselor saw
to ask a question about
um carpooling
um for
sorry I have to stand yes
we spoke about
um
travel costs for for staff and I
wondered whether one of the um
initiatives that you were looking at
would be carpooling for staff and
whether that could be achieved
um without too much
um
disruption and my second question
regards um Endeavor house
um having been in business myself and
been a tenant of a large building in the
city of London I did find that when I
pulled my concerns with other tenants
the landlord was much more liable to
listen to us particularly and I think
this is particularly the case in the
current environment where um
commercial landlords are having a very
tough time of it
and certainly would not like to lose any
tenants or have disruption with tenants
in there
so if if you could respond to that I
will be grateful
um if I do with the second one first and
I've just been messaging emulator Emily
atack actually uh as the assets lead and
she tells me there was a meeting today
uh uh with uh Endeavor House
Representatives to talk about energy so
hopefully that uh that that's
that set us on the road to some positive
discussions
um in terms of car pooling do you mean
sharing of starfig I mean I think
obviously we we do encourage that anyway
and certainly this um you know we do it
through uh internal comms messages Etc
um we are
um
we do also have pool cars Suffolk County
Council have pool cars that staff can
use so we're we're hoping to make that a
little bit more um get that out more
internal internal comms so that people
know about it I think some people
didn't know about it so there are things
we we are doing
um I think uh as part of sort of
um
refreshing the carbon production
management plan I think we need to
perhaps move some of those areas of work
further up the higher up the agenda
really in terms of uh staff
interventions I think it's been there's
been a big Focus historically on the big
the big items that that clearly have
brought some quick wins but I think we
need to now do more work with our staff
to encourage them to look at alternative
modes of transport
for you and then we have to move to
debate thank you um I won't be making
any cheap political points like
councilor Davis but um no doubt there'll
be an article written tomorrow about it
my question is the PV panels on all our
own Council Estates are getting quite
old now and have we got our plan in
place to modernize that PV panel system
because the development and
the panels has grown significantly since
they were first installed and I'm sure
through our estate we could gain a
greater benefit by renewing those panels
and the batteries that that store that
energy and would that make a significant
impact and what we are trying to achieve
thank you councilor yes I I do believe
that will make a huge Improvement there
is a scope for that to improve what we
already have
that is being worked through so you'll
see more of that in the uh before we put
up to 22 23 that we are putting together
a plan for them
I don't know if you only would like to
expand on it
um so I don't think as such a budget has
been set up set aside to replace them
which I think was your question
um what I would say is they are
performing quite well so
in the data a couple of weeks ago they
are performing a
good level
um
however that's one of the things that
we're going to be looking at in the
public sector decolonization bid that
hopefully we'll be able to put put in to
government towards the end of the year
um both a rollout but also potentially
looking at how we can upgrade them using
things like battery storage if it's if
it's viable
now councilors do you wish to enter into
debate or shall we just ask councilor
Potter to do a summing up Council award
thank you madam Cham at the risk of
scratching an open wound I will like to
remind members about the reasons for
them
for lunch building
we had two councils operating out of
half used buildings about fifteen Miles
apart officers traveling between the two
both buildings were old and unfit for
purpose
this building may have some problems
with its energy performance but it's
nothing compared with the province
courts Lane quartz Lane would have had
now so we are well shot of that place
and this is a much better location for
us so
um yes at the majority of the council
voted for the move
um six seven seven years ago 2016 we
voted and moved in 2017. it was the
right decision so
um can we just keep the Endeavor house
moving out of this discussion it's a
long time in the past now
thank you can we move to debate
you wish to debate councilor Holt
comment really I think it's a lot of
work on over the last four years and you
personally have been credit to achieving
that I think the work at Kingfisher the
solar carports which counts of beer was
a bit critical up I think it's a great
initiative and something we may be able
to build on
um so we've done an awful lot and I
think we should congratulate the
previous administration and those that
are still here for achieving that and I
look forward to achieving a lot more in
the next four years so it's more a
statement but I think we should
congratulate ourselves on what we've
done and look forward to the future and
achieving even greater things
yes chairman thank you um just a comment
really
um in relation to what councilor Holt
said and was
answered
um there was a question about PV panels
and things and what they produced by Ken
State and I would know this from my um
order and standards role that the PV
panels on our own Council houses in the
last Financial year brought in a third
of a million pounds in the feed in
tariff 350
000 pounds now why was the counter along
with um Clive arthy who started this
project and I'm quite proud that it's
still running and earning us quite a bit
of money our budget would be a bit sick
without it so um there's something to be
proud of I weren't sure councilor hope
whether you were there into that or not
because there are other things you
mentioned councilor States but these are
right across um the baber mid-suffolk
council houses and they're still a damn
good earner and we should be um thankful
and we need to expand that project even
more and it needs to be put on the um
industrial estate roofs as well because
that's where that's where the um the
real feed in tariffs lies leave the
fields for growing our crops and
vegetables stick the PV panels on the
industrial robes please thank you just a
point of clarity
would you like to sum up yes sorry
councilor Mabry
thank you
um yes you are you're quite right um
councilor Huron about about the PV
panels and that they do um give uh an
income to us and we should be very very
grateful um for that and they also help
obviously our residents too
um but can I just point out to you also
that it was Frank lawrenson who was
previous
Cabinet member for the environment who
actually proposed
um PV panels
um so he's he also needs a mention I
think because that's one one of the
things that you did follow through and
many residents are very grateful for it
thank you
it's definitely over to you now thank
you
so as this report was of course impacted
uh severely by covid
this new report that is incoming in the
Autumn to 2022-23 report the impact of
the projects specified throughout these
will definitely be visible tomorrow we
do accept and acknowledge I believe more
needs to be done
which is why the councils are rolling
out HBO to fleet vehicles to introduce
more solar PV to more Council buildings
and to install 25 charge points in the
district for electric vehicles those in
the latter specify targeting for
households requiring the on-street
charging facilities as part of the
recommendations of the report the task
and finish Group which I believe is
cross-party will review actions in the
carbon reduction management plans make
recommendations to accelerate the
program of intervention towards the
eventual Target of meeting Net Zero
thank you
I'll now ask the corporate manager
governance and Civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair that is now turning blue
for Christmas to cast their vote
councilor Riley can I take your vote
please
imagine chairman actually says on here
under 3.1 the contents of the greenhouse
gas emissions report
2021-22 appendix a to the report being
noted
so there's not a boat
yeah
but we can't we can't vote for both
we can yeah it's been taken together and
the second recommendation is that a task
and finish group is established to
review and refresh actions in the carbon
reduction management plan and that vote
is taken together
um
thank you chair that is 28 votes four
and one abstention
thank you so look that's carried
you now move to BC forward slash 234 11
review of the delivery of the 2023
District town and parish council
elections I'd like to invite the chief
executive to introduce this report
thank you madam chairman good evening
again councilors I'm presenting this
report to you as returning officer
rather than chief executive as you know
as it was reported at the time we
experienced some issues when running the
district town and Parish elections this
year and I'd like to apologize again for
the errors that were made and you may
have seen that apology has also been
sent to all of our towns and parishes
in response to the issues that we
experienced before polling day I
commissioned an external review from the
chief executive of the association of
electoral administrators and that was
done in consultation with the Electoral
commission as well
we've also conducted as you'll see from
the report we've also conducted an
extent an extended sorry internal
wash-up review as we do after every
election but on this occasion it was
done with Belton braces so to speak
given the issues we've experienced and
both of those reports both those reviews
are attached to the agenda appendix A
and B respectively
reassuringly the external report
confirms that the district town and
Parish elections were safely and
securely delivered and that there were
no inherent failings in our election
processes
and the review also notes the issues are
all resolved efficiently and effectively
and that women and that there were many
mitigating issues that were unlikely to
occur again in the future however whilst
that is of comfort I've taken personal
uh responsibility for these issues and
it take them extremely seriously and
we've already begun to address many of
them that are raised within the reports
it's essential for the council and you
know this I didn't you don't need to
hear this from me but it's essential for
the council and for local democracy that
everyone can have complete confidence in
our election processes and with that in
mind the Electoral commission have
updated since this report was published
they have updated me to confirm and I'll
read this out that following their
moderation process including a review of
the Errors By The Electoral coordination
sorry electoral coordination Advisory
Board and a final assessment by the
director of electoral Administration
guidance there are those are both
electoral commission bodies
we they have determined that the errors
do not require formal assessment and
they've brought their formal moderation
process to a close they will however
continue to work with us over the coming
weeks so that we can be assured and they
can be assured of the steps that we're
taking to avoid such errors occurring
again in the future and that will
include supporting us and our team with
appropriate guidance support and
challenge to create with us plans for
future polls as I just sort of provide
that update which isn't contained within
your report
um although the two reports the external
one and the independent one so the
internal one were commissioned
independently of one another as you can
see from my covering report there are a
lot of common themes that occur across
the two and I won't read those out you
can read that within the report in terms
of those common areas for improvement
and so our next steps is that we are now
developing a detailed action plan in
order to address all of the issues that
are raised by both the external and the
internal reports and subject to your
approval tonight it's my intention that
that draft action plan should come to
the Joint audit and standards committee
so they can look at that action
finally and so solely because I've got
the floor I thought it'd also be just be
useful to confirm to all counselors that
our annual electoral registration canvas
exercise that starts this week and so
our electors will be contacted directly
by the council to ask them to confirm
their details for registration purposes
I mentioned that because of course
sometimes when that happens you also get
contacted by a electors asking you the
question is this real is this from the
council and such alike so if you do get
any concerns it should be
straightforward but if any concerns are
raised directly with you as councilors
by the electorate please do get in
contact with the Electoral Services team
we'll be able to answer those queries
but I'm hoping you don't get any of
those because I'm hoping the electrics
are more than familiar with that annual
exercise now
so I can't clearly move the agenda
motion but I would call for a proposal
secondary if you wish to do so thank you
thank you Arthur
um I now need a proposer and seconder
to note the recommendation which is to
note the content of appendices A and B
and request that the joint audit and
standards committee review the draft
action plan arising from those reviews
so if you're in agreement I need a
proposal councilor Horan you're
proposing and councilor McGraw have you
got a question I'll take it after
okay I'll take you as a second to thank
you very much councilor beer now we have
we move on to questions so
to you
um uh I'll do my comments in debate but
a question
um
during the well before the election and
journal we were concerned all round the
amount of people that would be
um debarred from Photon because they
didn't turn up with the appropriate ID
um now I always go around my polling
stations and I've got three in great
cornard of two or three four times
during the course of the day to each one
met the staff there uh asked them how it
was going and particularly that point
and we didn't have too much of a problem
in great cornard in all honesty there
was people turned away because they
didn't have the appropriate ID most of
them came back with it which did
surprise me but there was a lot of
hoo-ha sound that people were
disenfranchised they couldn't vote do
you know what that figure is that's
that's my question
thank you councilor no off the top of my
head I don't but you are absolutely
right the overall impact of the changes
which required voters to bring voter
identification to the public stations
was very low
um nationally that's been reported more
broadly in off the top of my head it's
either 300 or 800 so I'm not going to be
quoted on either but and that's the
county-wide figure so that's not our
figure that's for the county as a whole
so yes if you then extrapolate in terms
of Bakers it is very low my concerns
just looking ahead to the next elections
is there was a loss of publicity that
went with that this time to make sure
that electors knew that this change was
coming in obviously what we don't know
is the number of electors who walked up
to the polling station saw the poster
and never came in
we only know the ones that came in were
turned away and came back again so there
is an element to which there's an
unknown aspect there my bigger concern
and yes I take this opportunity publicly
with YouTube to to advertise it again
that changes for all future actions not
just for that one just gone and
obviously the turnout for any future
general election in particular will be
significantly higher so we will need to
continue to increase the publicity and
would request that all of you do as well
ahead of all future elections to make
sure that voters know this is a
permanent change unless the electric
commission or the government decides to
change their mind but it seems unlikely
it's a permanent change and therefore
voters will need to continue to bring
identification every time they vote but
yes impact was low
any other questions counselor
respect chairman and chief
exact problem here that those who felt
in
limited as you perhaps normally need a
bit of encouragement just didn't bother
to turn up at all and we can't measure
that figure I would put it to you that
figure is greater than the ones you
might have mentioned we should be
encouraging everybody especially
first-time voters sometimes I did come
across quite a few people who were aged
um they didn't have the documents they
knew they didn't they should have been
quite entitled about but didn't even
bother to leave the house and that is
the biggest worry we need to get the
vote and figures up
um not put people not put people off and
what can be done about that
I knew there'd be a question at the end
um
absolutely yes
it is so it's not within our gift to
change the rules obviously we simply are
the ones who have to deliver the
mechanisms as prescribed to us by
government government has decided that
the right approach is to have vote
identification
um my personal view for what it's worth
is that it does feel slightly
disproportionate the amount of fraud
that was in elections which is why this
has been brought in is a very very small
nationally even smaller in areas such as
ours however it is the regime we will
implement it I think the only way in
which we can begin to measure exactly
what you describe councilor is to go
back and look at turnouts four years ago
but that's not the greatest guide
because that was four years ago and
certainly I would hope although I've not
seen any indication that this is the
case I would hope that as Government
reviews or rather as the electric
commission review and then government
does a further review of what forms of
identification are acceptable that a few
more forms of documentation might find
their way onto that list of acceptable
identification I know anecdotally for
example we had police officers turning
up with warrant cards trying to use
their own card as identification not an
allowed form of identification slightly
tricky for a presiding officer to tell a
police officer they're not allowed to
vote not ideal so yes absolutely and
particularly for younger voters I think
a lot of focus was put on the forms of
identification focusing on the older
voters for understandable reason not
proportionately on the younger voters
and what forms of identification they
may or more realistically probably don't
have and so I think that's an area that
I would hope is looked at for the future
the other way around is for us to
continue to encourage that if you don't
hold that form of identification or any
form of identification of course we are
able to provide you with it but again we
had very low low requests numbers in
terms of the voter authorization
certificates
um again I would hope for familiarity
people become more comfortable with that
and may well apply for that document in
the future but it is not the most
straightforward of exercises and nor
it's much easier just not to vote
unfortunately
yeah of course the best arts or
awareness to get a postal vote and then
you don't need it
the Parker
oh you've sought me over thank you
um yeah just a technical question
actually with regards to the software
there's much mentioned in the report
that there was a lack of familiarity
around the software but is that a
standard piece of software used by all
local authorities or do we have a
piecemeal not do we have a piecemeal
approach but is there a piecemeal
approach nationally
so as you can imagine elections is a
very specialist Niche area when it comes
to software provision there are
somewhere between three or four
providers nationally
that has been encouraged historically
rather than Simply Having one provider
on the basis that that level of
competition encourages Innovation and
therefore uh greater product and greater
cost savings potentially so there are
about three or four providers nationally
we switched just ahead of the 2022
elections to the current provider so we
have run elections not our district and
Parish elections but certainly the
police and crime commissioner elections
and the last County council elections on
this software and yes you're right as
alluded to within the report there is
any greater need for familiarity in
relation to the software they're all
much of a much list as you can imagine
ultimately they're all making sure that
they are consistent with the regulations
and the legislation are set up
nationally but at the same time they
which do it give us a slightly
differently and so it is important that
our team
offer in order to do so
um we as I say having recently changed I
think we're unlikely to change software
provider again there are also
opportunities that existed for example
with our previous software provider
whereby the postage and printing package
is part of the same relationship with
the software provider because as you can
imagine an awful lot with elections
hangs actually on paper rather than
digital and if you've got that direct
connection between the two elements both
from a financial savings perspective but
also from a risk mitigation perspective
that can be quite helpful so when we are
looking to procurement we don't just
look to the software we look at the
ancillary elements as well
any more questions or can we move to
debate
cancellers you need to debate on
accepting
the recommendation
so does anybody wish to open the debate
councilor beer
thank you madam chairman
um apologies Mr chief executive but I
cannot remember the name of the election
officer that ran the election for us uh
last time you can tell me his name
Edward McCready yeah well he did an
excellent job
um many times when I came into the
lecture office he was there
single-handed he did have one or two
people dropping in and out to help him
and he was really rushed off his feet I
felt and I did say that to him and I
think I may have known to you when I
caught you in a corridor there that he
needed more help and staff and
assistance because at election time
um I think it's what you tend to forget
a lot of existing counselors which
perhaps stand for re-election they go
along there and they've got lots of
papers that the public have wanted to
hand in the post of voting wanting forms
for this and that and what have you and
we were taking that valuable time
requesting all this from him and he was
doing it all by himself printing them
off getting getting them for us and uh
what have you and I and I I really felt
that
it was Paul's show that we didn't have
more staff help me and when I mentioned
this to him he did say he'd got some
stuff some of them will work from home
well how you can run an election working
from home I don't know but uh that
didn't seem to help the situation so
no and the question there's a debate
there you did say that
and so what I'm saying is yes he did an
excellent job
um I think we ran the elections quite
well I don't think there's any problem
there but there is room for improvement
and if it's more staff you need perhaps
at election time you need to take one or
two on thank you
it's really just a sort of technical
point because I think we could talk
about this at length but it occurs to me
that if we do that we'll actually be
preempting the joint audit and standards
committee reviewing the draft action
plan effectively we'd just be repeating
ourselves I wonder if uh perhaps it'd be
an idea to draw the debate to an early
conclusion
Riley
thank you
well ahead of the uh joint audit so they
I I would share with all my colleagues
that my experience in plantwood
um micro trading officer very nice young
lady well this is not a complaint really
a statement uh deemed that my way in
this meant I was campaigning for voting
and therefore I should not be within the
precincts of the working area and
moreover I should not be campaigning
within 200 meters of the polling station
when I asked where this figure came from
she told me it was in the Parliamentary
bill
and I told her that it was not my policy
to take advice or instruct from a
parliamentary bill but of course would
obey parliamentary Acts
we referred various problems up to the
next in line I think finally I
liberal has spoke to the returning
officer and it was then deemed that the
polling station precincts included the
whole building and if I want to go and
wear a rosette I should sit outside
and fortunately the weather was nice
police station staff provided me with a
a chair and I got the job so I'm not too
fussed about it but what I will say is I
did expect a better level or education
amongst within my presiding my police
station officer so my suggestion is in
this debate that next year we upgrade
the education and we upgrade the clarity
of the information provided to the staff
have a comment cancel award
focus on on this particular report
before and we've heard a lot about
people's problems with voter ID and
we've just heard about Council
O'Reilly's rosette but this report is is
into some of the specific
um failures problems with the way that
they mentioned
team was was run and it comes up with a
number of recommendations it's an
excellent It's a thorough report and I
think it's something we can all learn
from for the future so I'm very happy
with with what we've got here and yes
the the ordinance Sanders committee can
pick this up going forward so let's
focus on on this report and vote
accordingly thank you chairman
um yes
I'm reading this report and I'm
wondering how computerized the system
was in terms of somebody inputs the data
the input data now it's it's this is
this is is
not so much question as a point as
um was the outputs
what's the whole system tested properly
because
this is hopefully something I can
investigate it scrutiny audit and
scrutiny because it's it's a particular
area that I've been working in
it's almost AI but it would help it
would help make sure that the problems
that we saw wouldn't happen
hmm
yeah but
but not was it it wasn't to the scale of
this was it so again are you looking for
a question and answer or I'm just I'm
just asking well
I would like to know if it was
tested properly this has only just
occurred to me the returning officer is
is happy to answer your question
so as I alluded to earlier so the system
is a generic one so in that sense
testing for our Council shouldn't
particularly be different for testing
for another area however the setup for
our specific election in this case uh
elections both for the town parish and
for the district does require testing
and on page 91 of the reports on the
external review confirms the view of the
external uh person that at Future
elections the system should be set up
and tested much earlier than it was this
time so absolutely agree
Council award were you wanting to say uh
comments no so we can move to the vote
Yes yes so councilors you know the
routine
cancer so you will need to page down
um for this vote
um it is going to be turning blue thank
you
that's O'Reilly
foreign
chair that is unanimous thank you very
much
we now move on to counselor appointments
the appointments are listed on the
agenda
don't believe there are any further
changes or do we ask for change unless
anybody wants to change come off go on
move
so you just need
but I do need a proposer and a seconder
on the list that is in your packs
so Council Busby's proposing you can
have a second at council at Jameson
okay and that goes straight to a vote
appropriate since
certain host someone who's the lead on
the
twitch strategic whatever it is thinking
that we're both on because in the
minutes it said I think you were so
whereas I think I am so so the pistols
are done or you take the lead
Council I think it should be councilor
Busby who should be the lead and with
the professor Jameson this is up so if
you can have that clarification
I think I was telling you guys
thank you
have we accepted that
good
cancer riding the second
thank you very much
that is now in progress for councilors
to cast their vote to cancer Riley can I
take the vote
I agree thank you
chair that is unanimous again thank you
okay we now moved to motions on notice
to consider the motion on notice
received from councilor Jameson
councilor would you like to move your
motion
thank you madam chair
um I won't try to keep this fairly brief
okay
um
the motion is there in two parts as per
the table papers rather than the agenda
firstly back in 2019 we along with many
councils across the country declared a
climate emergency this was followed
shortly by a declaration of biodiversity
emergency
and there's Council Hulk pointed out
earlier since then a lot of good work
has been undertaken successfully
however since May we've had 14 new
councilors and um it would be nice if we
could call
bring this back today just to get the
new Council to reiterate their
commitment to this declaration
um that's the first part of the motion
the second part is for
opposed to for us is Council to sign up
to the UK 100 and the UK 100 is a
network of Highly ambitious local
councils across the country who seek to
advise the Implement plans for the
transition to clean energy
and
clans ambitious cost-effective and take
the public and business with them now a
lot there's lots of councils included in
Suffolk that have signed up to this it's
it's a free designer it's not and then
cost involved all we have to do is
commit to a pledge
um
to work and to learn and to
improve our Ambitions first
against Club neutral so it would be a
great thing for this Council to take
advantage of the knowledge that's
involved in this group to help us and to
help them
with their plans so that's the part two
parts of the one that is to reiterate
our Declaration of climate and
biodiversity see emergencies
and to sign up to the UK 100.
okay
well secondary is councilor Potter
yes I can confirm this thank you
we'll now move to the debate councilors
will only be allowed to speak once for
three minutes and this will be timed
councilor Mabry
and thank you thank you very much
the group
my group here have actually looked at
this we had no issue at all
with page one
but we cannot agree to page two
the reasons being we are a very rural
area it's already been talked about
um this evening by Fiona who's now
disappeared I looked up for her and
she's gone
um it's not possible to achieve what
some other councils
because we do not have the
transportation I've been in London this
week and getting
moving around London so much easier
because there are buses green buses
there are green trains and it's so much
easier we can't do it so much here
because of our rural area so we would
agree to page one but we would not agree
to page two
the other thing these concerns but if we
sign up to the UK 100 it also allows us
to join the UK 100 Countryside climate
Network which is aimed at rural councils
like ours so yes although we haven't got
the facilities and the pair of Tanks
City Kansas there is a group within this
UK 100 aimed at rural councils like ours
which
uh yes
the whole point of having a sustainable
travel action plan for the whole area is
link villages to towns you don't have to
do it along the roads you can do it
using Bridal piles footpaths
boats however you like
it's it works it's been done elsewhere
and it could be done inside it could be
done in baby
it could link your your ward councilor
Mayberry latinum to Sudbury it could be
done I've already
work done work on that route it would
cost a lot of money and it won't be done
quickly because it's going to take five
to ten years to actually achieve the
funding to do that but it can be done
we also need much better public
transport and we need Hopper buses and
or some other
mechanism
technology is changing we can't guess
what those mechanisms are now people are
working out systems all around the world
and how to get people to move in rural
areas using public transport that don't
involve double decker buses
so yeah it can be done it's just and we
could quite easily become part of UK
100.
thank you sorry counselor Riley I didn't
notice you but you did put your hand up
so please
thank you madam chair well
this motion indicates that since July
2019 four years ago there's been no
improvement in the climate or
biodiversity emergencies
moreover our new councilors are asked to
reiterate once again the commitment to
make our services carbon neutral by 2030
which we've already covered
what I'm unable to understand is why in
the last four years there's been no
improvement
and what we've been doing as a council
and how far have we Advanced on the
target of being targeted
carbon neutral by 2030. again you see
the other paper
2310 but should have been here
as far as this place is concerned this
is commitment without any understanding
as to where we are now
how much we've spent how much we're
going to spend and where we're going to
spend it and how will it be financed
is letting any coherence or meaningful
purposes
all I see here
is an un yet disclosed Pathway to
pillaging the taxpayers pockets to pay
for this component
which is why I'm unable to support this
motion this motion is merely Percy flage
it's a waste of time air and good trees
it is weak insipid and has no place in
coming to this assembly
thank you madam chair
oh I do have councilor McGraw and then
councilor Parker thank you chair it's
very kind of you um I'm a little
surprised and taken aback by the uh
Council O'Reilly just there
um Percy Flowers no less
um I noticed that he appears to believe
that the fact that there's no
improvement in the climate or
biodiversity emergence this does not
imply that nothing has changed
think it implies that there still is
such an emergency or other two emergency
they're not going away
and I will also disappointed to note
from councilor Mabry that the
conservative group will not be
supporting the additional wording for
the UK 100 cross party membership
um interesting because one of the things
we always spend our time doing is being
annoyed that we are not able to engage
with national government at a
significant level we all know that
dealing with this is going to require
National decisions when we make
decisions as a district council we have
less influence than a County Council or
a group of County well this is a hundred
at least and I suspect it will be a
great deal more than a hundred and I
also note it's peculiar that the
conservative of the party across the
floor aren't prepared to support
something that Suffolk County Council
have signed up for because in the
wording it actually States
agree on priorities for legislative and
Regulatory change while empowering them
to engage with national decision makers
isn't that what we're supposed to be
doing and frankly isn't that what a
conservative party a conservative
administration at Suffolk County Council
should be doing with a conservative
government
I mean please let's join the things up a
little bit so I will be supporting this
extension um I don't know what if if
it's possible to vote for half of the
motion and not vote for the other half
effectively what we're doing for the
benefit of the new councilors perhaps is
we're um renewing our vows is that fair
way of putting it but I mean to say I'm
saying I I like that bit and not that
bit and you can't just take it aside you
either vote for it or without don't vote
for it for you frankly most of the
conservatives in this rule room today
have voted for all the other things and
I can't see any problem with the
additional wording and
already approved by County Council a
conservative County Council
thank you councilor mccrore now
councilor Parker
yep thank you manager and I can be brief
again because um councilman chorus asked
many of the questions but
um in terms of resource how how will
this actually be resourced if we sign up
to this who's actually doing the work is
it is it is it member engagement is it
officer engagement
um and just as a comment dare I say
actually
um
um oddly paradoxically I don't think
actually the second part of that is uh
is passionate enough you know if it says
that um uh we're not obliged to take on
any of the policies that um that are
suggested I think we should be even more
ambitious and say that we should be
looking to take on some of those
policies if we're serious about making a
change thank you
bait
um
yeah
yes thank you
chairman councilors I think we should
all be leading and setting an example I
really do
some years back when I realized how
urgent this all was I um tore up my
passport and adopted no-fly
um
zone for myself but the number of times
and sometimes within this chamber people
said oh I just popped over the Portugal
I went for a holiday in Spain
um what are you not realizing the
biggest polluter is air travel
travel in total is about worth about 75
of the pollution that we're now
suffering from the worst is
air travel
so why are we still flying I don't mind
airplanes carrying vegetables or medical
supplies and if they can stick a few
people in the holes as well that's all
well and good
but we should not be um just using it as
a weekend trip there's even been
examples of
counselors I can remember about eight
years ago one councilor was constantly
flying to a place far away beginning
with sea
um
must have been clear thoughts I think or
maybe even further
can somebody remind me of where that was
Carolina oh was it North Carolina even
further wasn't it so I think my point is
please let's
show a real bit of leadership and stop
being Hypocrites please because if um if
we don't well we're all doomed literally
so let's have a bit of a responsibility
right across some political Spectrum
please thank you
councilor Holt
councilor beer you've spoken already
cancel to be a no you haven't and
counselor Newman and then I'd like I
think everybody would like to go to the
vote
because that's where I read this year
and had a very nice time
there's a lot of us do use air travel
it's a fundamental privilege and it's an
essential part of our economy as well so
you have to be careful what you wish for
um
ah there's a lot have been spoken about
travel and our rural location and
there's a lot of
um excitement from over here about the
prospect of us not using our cars and
relying on public transport but it's all
cuckoo
um it's not going to come in my lifetime
with that thing and I hope to live for
another 30 years
um
we have to live in the here and now we
have to look to the Future and protect
our planet don't get me wrong but we
have to be realistic on our location and
what our Ambitions are as a district
council and I just think we need to take
a breath and think about what we're
proposing
um
because we can talk all day long about
what we want what we hope to achieve
the money has to come from somewhere the
will has to come from somewhere and at
the moment the public aren't willing I
believe to give up their car to give up
privileged to use that facility and walk
and cycle from glemsford from Stansted
from lawshaw from shimplan from Somerton
from Boxford
artist I don't know if I mentioned then
sorry artists from the seven parishes
that I represent it's it's too much
um and the investment required to
provide a service for those people to
get on transport to get a Sudbury to go
to Berry
is beyond this District Council beyond
the County Council and Beyond the
government of here any government any
government the investment is too big and
too great we have to do our bit
little bits at a time and I'll back that
but but um we have to be realistic in
our ambitions
oh this is for Bryn Bryn should try
cruising it's very nice and you can go
from Southampton you don't even have to
fly
well well Madam chairman uh just follow
along from councilor Holt
um he's he's said all the things that I
would have said but we have a love
affair with the motor car and you're not
going to change that
we conservatives
are the friends of the motorists I'm
afraid some of you when I look around
this room are not and to suggest you've
torn up your passport I don't intend to
have my passport up I will fly like the
millions of other Britain's hard work
and British people who go on holiday for
all sorts of reasons and flowy and
they're not going to thank you for some
of this so just remember that and at the
end of the day as my friend here says
I've done a cruise earlier this year you
can go cruising but the bottom line the
bottom line is that the motorist is
definitely here to stay you've got to
work with them and some of the ideas
that you're trying to push forward
just won't work thank you
yeah
I've listened to what councilor beer and
councilor Holt um have just said and I
find it difficult to reconcile that with
with the motion we have in front of us
this motion is not not about wearing
hair shirts it's not about getting rid
of cars it's not about stopping us going
abroad although I think the
Mediterranean is probably not the best
place to go at the moment all this is
doing is is reaffirming the commitments
that this Council made prior to the
election
um in terms of our biodiversity action
plan and our sustainable transport plan
it's doing nothing more than that it's
not saying we've got to give up our cars
and
we can't fly anywhere I just
feel that the debate is getting away
from what we have in front of us yeah
I'm quite happy with this um with this
Mission as it stands it's it's just
um a continuation and a reaffirmation of
what we were already doing
Council award no I think we can move to
councilor Jameson for summing up
um yeah um and perhaps in your summing
up you might be able to address
[Music]
just quickly um
you can smooth summed up a lot of us and
the um
the second part they enjoyed in the UK
100 is about building ambitious plans
um Council house is got a point it is it
is challenging in a rural area to
to get away from the car and cars and
supported that and they're not going to
go away very quickly but unless you have
ambitious goals unless you have targets
you're never going to get anywhere
you're just going to sit
uh still so fair enough it's not gonna
happen you probably brought up and you
know last time as you say you may not
but unless we try
to try to get somewhere and working with
other councils you might find ambition
ideas ambitious plans and ways of doing
things that we've not even thought of
yet so
there might be possibilities that we can
do
yes that's basically the motion is as
was said previously by other councilors
it's reiterating where we were I don't
have the money or myself
um but um if we also work with other
councils and the government
find ways we may
be able to do it thank you
we now go to the vote
so you all know the routine thank you
chair that is now showing in blue for
cancers to cast a vote
that's not right can I take your vote
please
chair that is 20 votes 24 votes four
three against and two abstentions
thank you so that's carried thank you
very much we now move on to consider the
motion on notice received from Council
award
Council award would you like to move
your motion and I understand councilor
Busby as your seconder
that's correct thank you chairman
um
last item we're nearly the end
before proposing this motion I would
just like to briefly remind members of
the history behind it
in order to increase increase grid
transmission capacity to accommodate the
demand for electricity in the future and
the new energy generating capacity
provided by offshore wind farms National
Grid electricity transmission has
embarked on a major program known as the
great grid upgrade
part of this is a project to connect the
electricity from offshore is dangling
wind farms using 180 kilometers of high
voltage cables supported by pylons from
Norwich by bramford to twinstead oh
sorry to Tilbury
along with all County and District
councils affected by this project baber
has publicly stated its opposition and
preference for a strategic offshore grid
to support all offshore generation and
the interconnectors to Mainland Europe
labor and mid-suffolk District councils
stated opposition in a joint response to
last Summer's first non-strategy
consultation and will be doing so again
for the current second non-statutary
consultation
the then lead of mid-suffolk and I
followed this up with a letter to Greg
hands MP then minister of state of the
former base Department
we also wrote directly to the senior
project manager at nget
I do want to remind them is that
everyone agrees that the network must be
upgraded the debate is about how
East Anglia will bear the largest brunt
of the new offshore wind capacity and
the impact will be greatest on our
environment so we must get the
supporting infrastructure right
to conclude this motion which is going
to both councils this week will send a
message to our communities government
and nget that reinforces our formal
consultation response
similar motion will also be going to
cause the city council tomorrow
so I'd like to propose the motion as
presented in the papers thank you
chairman
thank you
we'll now move to debate
councilors Busby you have seconded this
have you not
you have
thank you ma'am well you're entering
debate no I I've
um chairman I wish to propose an
amendment to this motion
yeah okay
thank you thank you very much
um the uh the amendment is and it's not
too wordy you're all okay
the end of the second paragraph
to read the last two lines
um construction activities to
effectively minimize and mitigate harm
to suffix communities comma comma
environment and tourism
and the beginning of the next
paragraph it should be whilst the
and the idea of behind this amendment is
that our district is very important for
tourism and we should acknowledge that
latinum has been mentioned several times
tonight and I will reiterate and perhaps
the new councilors do not know but
lavanum on its own provides 7.5 million
pounds to the district from tourism and
I think tourism should be added to give
more Credence to what is being proposed
here thank you oh I'm proposing it and a
second Angela seconding
thank you
okay I mean that
Council award do you accept that
yeah I think so um although I I think
the the motion itself is is
um that part of its relating
specifically to the construction impact
on uh
the guitar communities and and the
environment yeah because there will be
significant construction part to the
environment I'm not necessarily sure to
what extent tourism is going to be
affected by either the construction or
indeed the presence of
um the pylons where they're going to be
pylons or the underground trenches where
they're going to go to the ground
trenches tourism is is a long-term
um
benefit to our district it's a long-term
part of our economy and will outlive the
well I'll be
saying yes but um
oh go on then yeah why not but hey but
not the worst but not the worst yeah not
I think the whilst is probably better
while it's just as dramatic
Ally we can keep that
or at least it was when I was at school
right exactly no
yes so we need to
accept
yes including ones
have you accepted it yes it's entirety
including whilst
um
chair you can't do that you've got to
either accept the amendment as it's
tabled
um or or not accept it you can't take
part of it well it's set to as table
thank you very much
lovely
[Music]
becomes a substantive motion and we go
to debate
go to the vote okay okay lovely even
better
so um chair that has now been changed to
agree emotional notice proposed by
Cancer Ward including the amendment
proposed by cancer Mabry so if you can
cast your votes please thank you
Castle arriving
approved thank you
councilor Davies are you having problems
would you like
you like okay lovely thank you
chair that is a unanimous vote thank you
very much wonderful and now the next
meeting is scheduled for Tuesday 19th of
September at 5 30 p.m and this meeting
is now closed